عند تحليل عمل القبه الحديديه نجد انها
تعتمد على جهاز الرادار الذي يتتبع ويرصد
الصواريخ المراد استهدافها ومن ثم يرسل
بيانات الصاروخ واتجاهه الى وحدات التحكم
بالاطلاق التي تحللها لتعطي الاوامر الى
قاذفه الصواريخ لاطلاق الصاروخ الاعتراض
وتستطيع اعتراض صواريخ في مدى 70 كيلومترا
وبحسب شركه رافائيل المصنعه للقبه
الحديديه فانه عند محاذاه الصاروخ
الاعتراض للصاروخ المستهدف فان الاول
ينفجر مطلقا مجموعه من الشظايا التي تتسبب
بتدمير الراس الحربي للصاروخ المستهدف
[موسيقى]
فعليا في الرؤوس الحربيه لصواريخ القبه لا
تحوي اي شظايا ويمكنك مشاهده ذلك من خلال
كاميرات السرعه العاليه فالذي يخرج عباره
عن نار ومعاذ بلاستيكيه التي تزيد من
الاثر وهذا ما شاهدته في عقاب الجرف
الصامد في مدن الجنوب اشكيلون واشدود وبير
السبع لا يوجد تاثير والموضوع عباره عن
كذبه كبيره
اخفاقات عمل القبه الحديديه التي رصدها
الخبير الاسرائيلي تعود بداياتها الى
العدوان الاسرائيلي على غزه عام 2012 حين
كانت القدرات الصاروخيه للفصائل
الفلسطينيه في اولى مراحل تطورها النوعي
خلال تلك الحرب نظرت بالصدفه في التلفاز
بعد ان كنتم منقطعا في الايام الاولى
للحرب وشاهدت مسارات الاعتراض التي تقوم
بها القبه الحديديه واعتقدت في البدايه ان
الاعتراض الاول كان غير موفق وفي الاعتراض
الثاني فهمت ان الموضوع منهج يسير وفق نمط
معين حيث ينطلق الصاروخ ومن ثم يتحرك
بزاويه الحاده نحو الارض بسرعه كبيره
لينفجر بعدها وهذا الموضوع تكرر كثيرا
خلال الاعتراض وعندها ادركت بوجود مشكله
نمطيه بمعنى وجود كذبه لانه من اجل اعتراض
قذيفه تسقط علينا بخط مستقيم تقريبا
فالواجب القيام به هو احتساب نقطه التقاء
مستقبليه والطيران نحوها بخ ط مستقيم وكل
ما تفعله القبه الحديديه كل شيء ما عدا
الانطلاق بخط مستقيم
هنا ترى الزاويه كبيره جدا فلا تتمكن
الشظايا التي تطلقها القبه الحديديه من
ضرب الطرف الامامي للراس الحربي لصاروخ
المدفعيه فهذا يخبرك يقينا من شكل خط
السير ان معترض القبه الحديديه اخطا الهدف
في هذه الحاله ما يمكنك رؤيته هو ان هذا
المعترض لم يشتبك مع صاروخ المدفعيه او
فيما لو اشتبك مع صاروخ المدفعيه فقد
تجاوزه صاروخ المدفعيه فاخطاه هذه
اعتراضات غير موفقه
[موسيقى]